we're going to begin the meeting of
landmark's commission and I'd ask Jenny
Fernandez to call the role
[Music]
please landmarks preservation commission
public hearing and meeting of August 3rd
2010 chair tney here Vice chair
Vango commissioner Bland here
commissioner Burns here commissioner
shapen here commissioner gner here
commissioner
Gratz commissioner Moore here
commissioner perer here commissioner
Ryan here commissioner
Washington okay thank you very much and
let me welcome everyone who's come to
this public meeting let me thank
Pace College Pace University judge
keading who has facilitated this uh
venue for us very generous and uh very
appropriate venue and obviously has the
capacity to uh to accommodate everyone
who wishes to be at the public meeting
and uh before our director of research
Mary Beth Betts begins her brief
presentation on
4547 Parkplace I want to explain exactly
where we are in the process and what to
expect today for those who are uh
perhaps new to the the procedure or not
as familiar as many others uh on July
12th 2010 the commission held a public
hearing to consider the possibility of
designating 4547 Parkplace as an
individual Landmark that public hearing
was the forum for public testimony and
it was
extensive and having heard that
testimony and considered all the
submitted materials that that hearing
was closed and the commission reconvenes
today as it customary arily does and
it's our normal routine after the public
hearing and after that discussion to
reconvene in a public meeting which we
are doing today to discuss whether in
the commissioner's judgment and the
Commissioners today are the as I said at
the last meeting we were there to listen
and to hear the public today uh it's our
turn if you will to to have in this
public meeting the opportunity to
ourselves have a conversation and a
discussion and decide and reconvene in
this meeting to discuss whether in our
Collective judgment this building meets
the criteria for designation under the
New York City landmarks law but first as
I alluded Mary Beth Betts will uh make
her presentation after that the
Commissioners will discuss and consider
whether to designate the building when
we have concluded our discussion we'll
take a vote that vote will be either to
designate the building or remove it from
the commission's calendar Mary Beth
please good morning Commissioners um a
public meeting I item number one is an
item proposed for designation LP
2434 45 to 47 Parkplace building at 45
to 47 Park Place Manhattan The Landmark
site is burough of Manhattan tax map
block 126 lot 9 in part consisting of
the portion of of the lot bounded by a
line beginning at the Southeastern
corner of the lot running Westerly along
the southern lot line 54t 5 in to the
southwestern corner of the 4547
Parkplace building then Northerly along
the exterior of the Western Wall of said
building and parallel with the easterly
side of West Broadway to the northern
lot line then easterly along the
northern lot line to the Eastern lot
line then southerly along the Eastern
lot line to the point of
beginning completed in 1857 to 58 this
five-story store and Loft building is a
fine example of the Italian Renaissance
inspired pazi that flourished from the
1850s through the 1870s in the former
textile and Dry Goods District on and
around Broadway near City Hall Park it
was constructed for Paul spafford and
Thomas tilletson Proprietors of one of
the city's most prominent shipping
firms as you can see on the map while
number 45 to 47 Parkplace shares a large
tax lot with another building only 45 to
47 parkplaces being considered for
landmark
designation
by drawing upon the architectural
vocabulary of the Italian Renaissance
pazo the Builders of Mercantile
structures like 45 to 47 Parkplace
sought to project an image of prestige
and economic power the building retains
much of its historic fabric including
its original ground floor Corinthian
colonade cast by Daniel D Badger and
Company its stone-faced upper floors
appear much as they did when the
building opened featuring molded window
surrounds molded projecting lentils
bracketed Sills and second floor
balconet with faux turned balls flanking
the building's simple continuous cornice
or two scroll brackets it also retains
many of its historic likely original 2
over two double hung Windows although
their glazing has been painted
alterations include the replacement of
its storefront infill and the
installation of a metal fire escape
which probably dates from from the early
20th
century thank you thank you very much
Mary Beth and I will begin this
conversation and discussion and uh I've
listened closely and carefully to all
the arguments that have been presented
both for and against designation of 45
Parkplace a building first considered
for landmark status 1989 have we have
just heard it was built as a speculative
building in a style that had been made
popular by the nearby at Stewart
building at Broadway in Chambers Street
It's relatively intact and the building
is located on a side street adjacent to
other buildings that were built at
different times and have not been
calendared by this commission as I
stated at the public hearing under the
landmarks law the question we must
answer is whether the building has a
quote special character or special
historical or aesthetic interest or
value as part of the development
Heritage or cultural characteristics of
the city state or nation in reaching a
decision my part of my process was I
take note of the fact that the
commission has designated four historic
districts in the immediate vicinity of
this building in 1991 and 92 just two
years after Park Place was first brought
forward for consideration those historic
districts contain many examples of the
store and Loft buildings that of that
characterize the early development of
Tribeca these districts fully Express in
my judgment the uh history of tribeca's
development by including not only store
and Loft buildings of similar vintage to
the Parkplace 45 Parkplace but also many
examples of the building types and
styles that developed after the mid 19
century I also take note of the fact
that the commission recently designated
two other store and Loft buildings
nearby that are of similar vintage and
style 2325 Parkplace and 311 Broadway
and let me quickly go to those those two
uh designations uh these recent
designations when I compare and part of
the exercise here as this commission
exercis that this is the commission
that's that is the expert agency in
matters of this kind it is up to this
commission and the discretion of the
Commissioners based on all the the facts
and circumstances and material before us
to exercise judgment and discretion
about the the whether or not buildings
uh qualify or rise to the level of
landmark so as part of that process for
me and I I believe others will hear from
others in a moment uh in reviewing those
other recent designations when I compare
4547 Park Place to the designated 2325
Parkplace I believe the latter is a
better example of the type and style of
building it's more ornate example of the
style and furthermore was designed by
Samuel Adams Warner an architect who was
known for this type of building and
45 in contrast is simpler in design and
its architect its architect is unknown
when I compare 45 Parkplace to the
designated building at 311 Broadway I
believe that while the former is more
intact and perhaps a better example of
the building type it is located on the
side street whereas 311 Broadway is a
rare remaining example of this type of
building on the main commercial
thoroughfare of the area Broadway uh I
should note that the Tribeca East
historic district contains a half block
row of buildings on the north side of
Worth Street between Broadway and church
that are almost identical in design and
age as 45 47 Parkplace by virtue of
their continuity number this row of
buildings has a sense of place and
streetcape that paints a vibrant and
convincing picture of what this part of
the city was like when this style of
store and Loft buildings were common um
I've carefully considered also the other
architectural social historical and
cultural reasons that have been put
forth in favor of designation and
ultimately find them unpersuasive in
terms of this decision uh that we will
make finally I note that both I note
that both the city councilwoman
representing this area and the local
community board have both expressed
their opposition to the designation of
this building and for all these reasons
that I've just stated I've come to the
conclusion that 45 547 Parkplace does
not rise to the level of an individual
landmark and I will vote to remove it
from the commission's calendar we're
going to have the rest of the
Commissioners weigh in I have a
statement that I will Briefly summarize
at the end from a commissioner who
couldn't be here and then we will take a
vote commissioner
Bland this go thank
you um I've also spent um a lot of time
thinking about this case and a lot of
time walking the neighborhood uh with my
eyes and my mind wide open I've spent a
lot of time thinking about and studying
what an individual Landmark is in our
city that has only about 1,00 of them
out of a total of 1 million
buildings I agree with much of what the
chairman has just um stated but I have
my own thoughts and would like to
continue reading my my my own thoughts
here in this statement that I've
prepared although spec built 45
Parkplace is a handsome
well-proportioned and generally intact
commercial store and Loft building of
the Italian Renaissance Palazo style it
fits in with the streetcape and with its
neighbors but it does not really stand
out although we know from probable
conjecture that the ground
Floor cast iron Corinthian columns are
from the well-regarded Daniel D Badger
Foundry we do not know who designed the
building who the architect was many of
the other Palazo buildings were designed
by prominent architects of the
day additionally I noted that key
preservation
Advocates the municipal art Society the
historic district district council and
the landmarks Conservancy did not
support the nomination of 45 Park Place
as an individual landmark in
1989 and did not testify in support at
our recent hearing
either these actions or
inaction of these activist Watchdogs of
our City's historic resources spoke
loudly to
me finally I noted in my many walks up
and down the blocks surrounding
Parkplace that many Palazo buildings
still exist cheek by jowel creating
whole street
Scapes the story of the of The Palazo
building typology in New York became
visually clear to me as it had not when
I stood in front of 45 Park Place
isolated as it is from other ploto
buildings in other words these handsome
Palazo buildings reveal their historical
meaning best when seen in whole groups
I.E in a historic
district so I have come to believe that
this is the way New Yorkers in the
future will be able to best understand
and interpret the brief glory of the
commercial ploto typology in groups and
within historic
districts so therefore I do not think
that 45 Parkplace exhibits by itself the
special character or aesthetic interest
required of it to join the rare company
of the other 1100 individual landmarks
in the city of New York thank you
commissioner
chapen we are here today to consider
whether 4547 Parkplace should be
designated an individual
Landmark while individual landmarks are
not limited to works of great Architects
or buildings that are associated with
important people or events they should
have some special character or special
historical or aesthetic interest or
value or a combination of these
qualities not every old building even
those more than a century old should be
designated as an individual
Landmark after carefully considering
Parkplace I find that it was not
designed by a noted architect but by an
unknown
architect moreover it was not an
exceptional example in either design or
decorative features of the Italian
Renaissance inspired pazo style and does
not rise to the level of its near
neighbor 2325 five Parkplace and
certainly not to that of the at Stewart
building that inspired so many buildings
of this type store and Loft buildings of
this type are also well represented in
the Tribeca East historic
district the absence of support for
designation from preservation groups
both during the first reviews of this
area in 1989 and 90 and today re
reinforces the assessment that this is
not a building of special aesthetic
character
with regard to the building's history it
was probably built as a speculative
building and was occupied by a variety
of commercial Enterprises with no
consistent history of use the most
interesting occupant was probably the
American Press Association from 1893 to
1910 but I do not find this single piece
of the buildings uh history compelling
evidence to Warrant
designation for all these these reasons
I do not support designation of 45 47
parkplacees an individual landmark and I
agree with the remarks of chair tyy and
commissioner
Bland commissioner Pearl
mot uh yes um as has already been stated
this building was calendared in
1989 in the years since buildings of its
type age and style have been included in
numerous historic districts although
this building might be a contributing
member of an historic district that is
not the proposal before us today instead
it is being considered as an individual
landmark and its character style and
detailing do not rise to the high
standard that that level
requires commissioner
Moore thank you Mr chair I agree with
much as that has been said I appreciate
the what we are not considering use of
this building or religion then I would
have to admit that I would be somewhere
between the Council of John J and John
lennin John Jay a founding father in New
Yorker was the first Chief Justice of
the United States Supreme Court and John
Lenin also a New Yorker who in his
wonderful song Imagine wrote astutely
about
religion I will for public awareness
make one historical note about adjacent
Church Street for which it is a
veritable historic district itself of
first churches of a variety of
denominations over the last 370 years
the first property owner on Church
Street and Parkplace was a Dutch
minister of our earliest and oldest
Protestant Dutch Reformed Church in the
1640s later the property of the city's
second oldest church Episcopal Trinity
Church also on church is the yard of St
Paul's Church where our nation's first
inauguration service of George
Washington took place the city's oldest
Catholic Church St peters's at the
corner of barlay and church is on Church
Street the first African-American church
mother am Zion was at church in Leonard
and perhaps the closest of the historic
churches to Ground Zero was the St
Nicholas Greek Orthodox Church on
Liberty Street which was destroyed on
911 I would like for a few moments to
pay attention to 4547 Parkplace as a
significant address made important in a
split second on the morning of
911 which I will review from my own
personal experience on
911 at 9:03 a.m. when United Airlines
flight 175 hit the South Tower we all
witnessed the last moments of United
Airlines flight 175 and the lives lost
in that moment and we watched it replay
over and over on television I probably
watched it as much as anybody because I
had just come out of the World Trade
Center subway station at Chambers in
Church Street when it
happened I witnessed it from chambers
and in Church Street where none of us
knew that the fireball which we saw rise
up the tower had been caused by a plane
crash from my angle I could not see a
plane hitting the tower only the huge
ball of
fire I had just come out of the subway
to hear an explosion in a loud gasp from
people on Church Street I looked up to
see the fire climbing the tower somebody
yelled it was a bomb but pieces were
shooting out of the building and
spraying down toward us I didn't know it
was a plane engine a tire f SL and a
landing gear I had no idea what I was
witnessing I thought a movie was being
made and I thought it was being made
dangerously close to the public the fire
seemed to be out but the building looked
like it had been badly
damaged it was a moment when I was
trying to figure out what was happening
that I heard someone say in a tone of
absolute disbelief people are jumping
from the
building as I heard it I was looking at
it I saw two people falling down the
building if I hadn't heard those words
at the exact place that I was
looking I don't think I would have known
what I was seeing I knew it wasn't a
movie I saw three more people
dropping a few seconds or a few minutes
later I really don't know I have no idea
how long I stood looking at the sky but
I heard another person near me say that
a plane had hit the North Tower by
accident he
said I my eyes had been locked in on the
space between the two towers and I
looked to The North Face of the North
Tower and I saw a gaping huge smoldering
black hole from American Airlines flight
11 and it was set against the backdrop
of a beautiful blue sky I've never seen
a photograph that conveyed the enormous
size of that hole it did not look like
the building should even be
standing but it did not look like an
accident on probably the most beautiful
Clear Blue Sky of the Century my instant
thought was that America was being
attacked by
terrorists before I turned to leave I
looked up at both buildings and prayed
for the lives of the people I had seen
die or dying and for those many many
people who had already died whom I just
knew were going to
die that more people emergency workers
firefighters and police would actually
enter those Towers to save lives will
never be lost on
me for almost 10 years now including
this morning whenever I come out of the
Subway at chamers Street or I see the
area of the sky above the World Trade
Centers I find the place where the
towers stood and I think about 911 and I
think about those
people I don't want to confuse the
issues about 47 Parkplace it is not
directly on Ground Zero but it is a part
of ground zero and that's what gives its
address its space great
significance it cannot be seen at all
from ground
zero to the issue of designation as an
individual Landmark Mr
chair I agree with what has been said I
do not find the importance of 47 Park
Place to be its architecture it is in
proximity particularly on Chamber Street
of some of the finest cast iron
buildings ever made but it is not itself
near their
distinction I do I do think about the
significance though of its connection to
the events of September 11th
2001 however I I make it akin to a guard
rail on the highway where fatalities
fatalities have occurred the guard rail
is not preserved likewise the memory of
that day does not reside in the landing
gear or the building I believe it
resides in its space its
address if you will its connection to
the sequence of horrific events on
911 last I look we do not Landmark the
sky but I wish we could I do not believe
it should be landmarked but it should be
marked not necessarily with just a
plaque but in the public mind whether
the cast iron rusts and falls apart or
whether it is replaced by the most
famous Community Center in the world or
a church its space will always
memorialize the people who were in those
Plains and in those buildings and in the
sky I do not support the designation of
this property thank you commissioner
Ryan it is important to restate what the
basis for decisions is by the landmarks
preservation commission the law which
established the commission is clear that
the use of a building may not be
considered in determining its worthiness
to be or to not be a New York City
Landmark time and again an owner or
developer asks us to make a decision on
a property that will essentially be a
ruling on land use or zoning we demure
as I will demure now 45 to 47 Parkplace
does not rise to the necessary standard
to be designated an individual New York
City Landmark this type of store and
Loft building is widely represented
throughout Lower Manhattan in many of
our historic districts it is not in a
row of similar buildings which would
increase
importance there is no special cultural
history represented by 45 to 47 Park
Place its various owners and tenants
represent the everyday progression of
Commerce in New York City the location
of 4547 Parkplace on a side street is
the same as many such buildings that are
in the lower Manhattan historic
districts there is no known architect
who is responsible for the design of
this building in fact there are fewer
designed elements on 4547 s Parkplace
than other similar store and Loft
buildings lastly although it is not a
Criterion for designation it is worth
noting that both the community board and
the city council representative are
opposed to
designation after careful consideration
of the facts and in agreement with the
chair and my colleagues it is my opinion
that 4547 Parkplace does not meet the
standards of an individual New York City
landmark thank you commissioner
Burns uh as much as I would like to
opine about the appropriateness of an
Islamic Center two M two blocks from
Ground Zero I find that I must adopt the
stricter humbler stance of a landmarks
commissioner which is the worthiness of
45 Park Place as an individual Landmark
buildings of this character that is a
commercial pazo style building from the
1850s have been prot protected mainly as
parts of significant Landmark districts
notably four districts in Tribeca 45
Parkplace is a relatively well preserved
example of a style that is significant
in that it pointed away from more
romantic Styles such as italianate and
Gothic Revival toward what would
culminate in the mature classically
inspired work by McKim Meen white and
others a generation later the standards
of quality for an individual landmark
are much higher than those for buildings
in a landmark District they might
include being designed by a noted
architect or being associated
significantly with a historic event or
it might be a building of such Rarity
such as a federal house that even modest
examples should be preserved it might
even be significant in that it is an
unusual Survivor of an earlier pattern
of development such as a townhouse on
West End
Avenue while the case a 45 Park Place
scores points in several categories it
does not make the final Mark in my book
one it is a good but not exceptional
example of its style and was designed by
an unknown architect two there are
reasonably large numbers of these
buildings already protected in lower
Manhattan and they are not that rare
three its main historical significance
is its association with the events of
9/11 but the debris field around Ground
Zero was widespread and one cannot
designate hundreds of buildings on that
Criterion alone four its location on a
side street was a commonplace one I went
to view 311 Broadway and while it is not
as intact architecturally as 45 Park
Place it is the last survivor of the
pazo type on Broadway New York's Chief
thoroughfare on these grounds it
qualifies as an individual ual Landmark
while I would certainly include it as
worthy of inclusion in a landmark
District the neighborhood around it is
not of District quality for these
reasons and those articulated by other
members of the commission I conclude
that 45 Park Place is not of sufficient
nature to be designated as an individual
Landmark thank you commissioner
Washington a hard part of our task is
often to try to divorce ourselves from
the reasons for landmarking which have
nothing to do with landmarking
law the question is often how many
buildings of a particular style
representing a particular era or period
must be preserved to inform future
generations of the importance of that
period while the cast down cast iron era
has been recognized as an important
architectural period and the history of
New York
architecture not every cast iron build
building or building with cast iron
features should or must be preserved to
create this Legacy having heard the
historical and Architectural reasons
proposed for the landmarking of 4547
Parkplace I find that the building
itself falls short of the distinctive
features or historical background
present in many of the other cast iron
buildings in the area such as those
mentioned before um 23 Park Place and
311 Broadway which have been
landmarked in addition the fact that
other landmarked buildings in the same
area have more architectural possess
more architectural details are more
onate and are more unique all of these
reasons um lead me to the conclusion
that it's not possible for me to support
the landmarking of
4547 Parkplace as an individual Landmark
thank you before I call on commissioner
gner Briefly summarize as I said I would
Roberto Gratz who's not here today asked
me to read a very short statement when
as follows when we at landmarks are
asked to decide if a building is worthy
of individual designation we are asked
to think about the specific building in
a very different context than for a
historic district we are given detailed
information on the building by staff and
presented with additional detailed
information at a public hearing most
importantly the building under
consideration must rise to a higher
standard as an individual inmark than
necessary for a historic district in
this case I have found nothing in either
staff research or presentations at the
public hearing to persuade me that 45
Parkplace is worthy of a singular
designation in fact very little
information at the public hearing
supported the substance of a landmarks
designation the most compelling
testimony underscore the inadequacy of
45 as a singular building this partial
cast iron facad is an interesting and
appealing one at the street level at
least at the street level I would hope
the building could be deconstructed and
the worthy Parts reused on another site
however those few worthy parts do not
add up to a single individual Lark and
then I will now ask commissioner gner
please sure um I too uh as my fellow
Commissioners have stated have given
this a great deal of thought and I
walked the uh area and looked at the
building and the surrounding buildings
and the ones that we've compared it to
um as we all know it was built as a
speculative uh building designed by an
unknown architect and uh the building
was calendared in
1989 and although the commission saw the
building or the um we never moved to
designate it even uh to include it as
part of the historic districts uh nor
was there support by any of the
preservation groups uh for this building
uh it's a typical store and laof
building and although it has its um its
special character it's not unique and it
doesn't come up to the standards of the
2325 uh building which is a better
example of what was designated um even
though the owner was opposed to
designating that building uh in addition
4547 underwent a number of alterations
the window design and the lentils uh of
the lentils and the molded surrounds are
the same on all floor upper
floors um the uh 3 to five stories have
bracketed Sills below the Second Story
Windows the Sills are replaced by
ballustrades that spin the width of each
window the cornice is simple flanked by
two scrolled brackets uh one at either
end of the double windows with a visible
seam in between the two buildings in
comparison the 23 to 25 Park place's
most impressive feature is the hierarchy
of fenestration uh with richly carved
surrounds that the architect Warner
designed for the upper stories also the
cornices are significantly more detailed
uh we must make this decision based on
the true value of this building and its
place with others of similar vintage and
style um for all these reasons I believe
that
4547 Park Place does not rise to the
level of the 1100 individual landmarks
in this city it is not rich enough and
there are designated examples of this
style which are of a much higher
quality thank you thank you all
Commissioners I will make a motion now
to remove this building from the
landmarks preservation calendar I move
for the reason set forth in the
discussion that the building at 4547
Park Place in the burough of Manhattan
lacks a special character or special
historical or aesthetic interest or
value as part of the development
Heritage or cultural characteristics of
the city state or nation and that the
building in Manhattan tax map block one
26 lot n in part be removed from the
landmarks preservation commission's
calendar second I second all in favor I
opposed count that vote to be nine to
zero in favor of removing the landmarks
pres removing this building from the
landmarks preservation commission's
calendar and conclude the meeting thank
you all very
much